what's up gamers today we're playing
with Instagram filters have you guys
seen this have you seen these funnies
filters that's hilarious
I'm a dog no way I'm not a dog I'm an
I'm an e girl trying to look attractive
okay any time I don't have internet I
always go on Instagram and I check out
these filters and I'm always like yeah
this is mildly interesting but I never
post them because it's like what am I
gonna do what I'm gonna do hey look I
got like sprinkles hey look aa big okay
this one is funny yeah fine
but I thought today I'll entertain
myself with you guys because I love you
know the reason why is because that now
you can down low you get download okay
what does it look like I don't have eyes
oh this thing is I can move as well oh I
love this one this one is a gem wait
hold on hold up let me try something
yeah
what is this Oh Jojo break a peg I'm in
anime my dream has come true this is
okay you like this why am i filming this
I'm sorry damn that looks creepy me when
I see snacks in the drawer oh my god
relatable oh my god I think this one has
audio it does
bruh whoa I'm in the nether ah Jesus
Christ make it stop what I bet if I
don't know bro
Oh what I can change okay so that
good said where are you Oh God you're
again you can smell again don't go don't
go need an outlet how did he do this
this is sick
oh I'm not a girl there you go I'm not
this either wait Kashi Kashi from Naruto
Shippuden making a ninja sign wow this
one is so cool I'll definitely post this
one I don't understand people that use
these own ironically can you explain
this to me tap the plate
oh it's piercings so this is how I would
look like with piercings wow that's so
cool
can we do a tongue one hey hey uh-huh
hey guys it's me parent disappointment I
don't know if I understand the purpose
of this can someone help Yelp I am in
game boy help let me out
stop why who made this and why that's
scary
yeah he's touching his eye yeah wearing
contact lenses gamers don't be afraid me
when I see booty so relatable listen I
know this is the lame video but I'm
having fun okay
I'm on this one because it works with
two people if Marseille was here oh wait
she is gotta get really yeah no me too
damn is it me or is my Chi looking hella
sexy so let's download a couple more oh
no how god is bail delve in what is a
stupid face I can't really see I'd be
way better eager eyes they say the
shadows in my room can't take back the
love that I gave you oh god it's so hard
being a gamer uh-huh it sounds kind of
cool I like it though why don't they
make filters for dogs that'd be so sick
so you can put filters on your dog
I say smart things because I have a big
brain okay this better be epic cuz I've
always dreamt about having a penguin on
my oh my god there's a little pig can
you see it is it the Madagascar penguin
Kowalski Kowalski status report question
mark one place you better sponsor me
after this
oh boy oh boy
hey guys it's shitty wrapper here gonna
rap about drugs then how sad everything
is by Mac I'm mad about Batman god these
are so bad right now it's quite all
right I am really good at pokemon
impressions I know you're impressed you
have a freak - squirtle squirtle
no way please tell me this is a filter
for dogs now okay
okay okay wake up come on look in come
on do it you're a demon Edgar you're a
literal demon look into the camera
why don't work hmm hey Edgar look at me
use just like you again hello hey woof
woof I go peepee I want poopoo oh I'm so
annoying
I'm so annoying even though I'm eight
years old I'm so annoying but you're so
cute on camera hmm you just got roasted
again hey look it's me annoying again
alright wait hey Edgar how's it going
back is it gonna do it is he gonna do it
hit the corner
oh come on hit the corner hit the corner
oh so close ah the good old faces which
what happens if I'm with myself try with
friends this is so sad
as I have belt Delphine up I might as
well well that's so cool okay so I'm
already wearing headphones Wow amazing
hey guys it's me I have this microphone
taped to my face no stop oh why am i
choking on the microphone help me help
me the microphone know me when I'm big
braining you fool you stinky brain fool
i destroying you by sheer mental power
nothing displays how smart you are by
geometrics on the screen I'm gonna say
it I'm gonna say it
Frick oh damn it
Oh am I don't look at my Pippi
don't look at my Pippi oh god stop go
away hand what's you want to know how I
got - gosh brows I haven't seen the
Joker yet this is so sad
yeah I'm sure this will never be used
when I own my next oopsy I'm basically
giving free material away this is not a
P oh my god what is things I look good
bald I'm not gonna lie I would freak
myself bald kind of want to touch it
damn it I can't oh come on he looks so
much better
Jesus Lord ah Oh what I feel like you
need to trip out and do oh my god I am
freaking out
I am freaking sohma's a ba yell pl
I am trapped in another time so what's
the point of this
Wow
that's so cool oh my god hey hey oh oh
that's weird
oh okay this is see I tell I tell you
guys just take some drugs don't do drugs
kids but take some drugs Oh what I see
inside me ah Jesus stole PewDiePie wave
question mark oh Jesus
oh wow I kinda want to suck on them is
that weird is that weird does that make
you weird oh maybe I can maybe I can
although how would I do it I'm so sad
I'm crying my own eyes I'm literally
crying my al-asad yeah yeah oh no oh oh
oh no all right stop it's time to stop
well this is why I'm afraid of doing
drugs because this is what I imagine it
will be like and I will just be scared
stop whoa holy mokey smokey my face
along ye oh no take it off take it off
oh oh this is the way truly am please
accept me please accept me for who I am
all right Loki I'm kind of cute though
come on yeah oh oh
so that's that's something yeah I'll
freak myself I'll say it I'll freak
myself yes I'm a blue-eyes White Dragon
will you use Dark Magician oh you guys
okay that's kind of cool dude everyone's
sporting this white hair beard look I
did it first and now I look like generic
white person kind of sad how the one's
tagged funny just aren't funny at all
like what is this someone literally just
took the mic face at least do Shrek or
something epic all right guys it's time
for me to reveal who I really am
peach I mean how's it going browse it is
me pizza there's a stigma there's a
stigma against pizza people I hope that
by making this video I can draw I can't
look away it's like a train wreck I like
it oh my god
feel very self-obsessed this video cuz
I'm just looking at myself I just know
oh my god it's me look our child it's so
beautiful and it's speaking the same way
as us I'm so proud of our child hello
little child hello little one you're
gonna grow up to become a youtuber one
day hey hey he's beautiful
he will be the number one yes we created
him the number one youtuber yes he's
going to make Instagram face filter
videos but my god they will make views
will be rich yes and baby is already
learning exactly what how's it going
bros my name is excellent
yes he's learning quickly talk about
eyebrows
Nebraska's then changed to
nine-year-olds confuse them make them
one a subscriber so dumb alright gamers
hope you guys enjoy this video smash
like if you did before you click away I
have important announcement it's
something that I wanted to say for a
very much by the March
check out the March check out the much
bye oh my god got them again well you
haven't tried to Bruce emulator at City
after 50 million outros much go just
down it's still relevant just download
it